so the ability to turn down feedback and
create boundaries is crucial to
receiving feedback well and really to
creating healthy relationships one of
the paradoxes of receiving feedback well
is that in order to be able to say yes
you also have to be able to say no if
you can't say no to feedback what ends
up happening is you're constantly saying
yes and maybe resentment builds up and
then instead of actually engaging and
having a conversation we might just end
up fleeing their relationship altogether
because there's just too much pressure
in it so there are three boundaries that
are useful one is simply saying I'm
willing to listen to your thoughts in
your advice but I may not take it
another is saying the place that I'm in
right now your advice is not helpful so
I would prefer that you not give it to
me and then the most stringent boundary
is saying do not give me this advice and
if you continue to give me this advice
I'm going to have to leave the
relationship or I'm going to have to
there going to be some consequences that
I have to impose so one key in turning
down feedback is to use the word and and
what that really means is - you can be
firm in turning down feedback but also
appreciate the potentially positive
intentions that someone has that you're
your friend or sibling maybe giving you
advice on dating so much driving you
crazy but their intention is positive so
you can say you know I understand that
you care about me and you love me and
you want me to have a happy life at the
same time in other words and and it's
having a negative impact on me so you
can appreciate the intention and then
also turn down the actual feedback it's
important when turning down feedback to
be specific don't simply say you're
driving me crazy or stop annoying me or
stop giving me feedback Beeks be
explicit and specific about the topic
that is upsetting you so for example if
a friend is staying with you over the
weekend say if you're going to stay here
for the weekend I request that you not
give me advice about my parenting or
that you not comment on
printing and then explain why explain
why it's upsetting that gives the other
person at least a fighting chance of
complying with what's important - it's
also useful to be specific about the
time frame so is this your you're asking
as you get your feet under you as a new
parent is this something that you you
just would like their complaints the
first few months that they not be
badgering you or maybe maybe it's your
old life it's also important if there
are going to be consequences if if if
you're thinking gee if you're going to
continually give me advice about my
parenting it's going to cause me to try
to avoid you sometimes and that's
upsetting for me as well as for you and
so if that's the case if you really are
going to be avoiding the person they
should know the potential consequences
and then the last piece of it is to be
is to get their assent in other words to
say so I've made a request um is it
clear to you and is that something that
you can agree to and once they've signed
on they have a certain level of
commitment to it so they can say you
know hopefully they say yes I won't
mention your parenting style and then if
they do it's easier for you to reference
it as well so if I've decided that I'm
not changing I've created a boundary
that's fine but we we all have a duty if
we're if we're living or working with
other people we also have social
interactions with them and
responsibilities toward them so for
example let's say you're my spouse and
you've been encouraging me to try some
medication for a DD and maybe I've tried
or maybe I've just decided I'm simply
not going to I don't like it so you're
setting a boundary you're giving any
feedback I'm not taking the feedback and
that's your right but at the end of the
day we also have the duty to think about
the other person and to think about so
if I'm not going to take the medication
what can I do at least to make things
better for you so maybe each morning
we'll go over a joint list of the tasks
that need to get done today and we'll
just sort of problem solve together what
would be helpful to you what's going to
be
to me and what might actually help the
situation
you wanted me a Tec medication I'm not
going to that's the boundary but that
doesn't mean I don't have a
responsibility to try to to try to make
things better for both of us